with growth booming so is our housing
market especially here in southern
nevada it's enticing a lot of investors
too
joe mohler is live near the 2 15 in
windmill and jones with
why people want to put their money in
our state joe
well despite the pandemic investors are
still keeping their eye here on
nevada and las vegas take a look behind
me here we are in henderson this home is
being renovated
uh someone who lives in another state
actually bought this to rent it out
the growth and rising rent in southern
nevada is keeping
investors interested but all of our
clients live in
other states or countries eric fernwood
and cleo lee are owners of fernwood real
estate investment group
we are actually seeing a lot more
interest
with more people moving to las vegas low
taxes and an economy that is becoming
more diverse
investors are interested in making their
money grow here there's a combination of
factors
one has to do with the pro-business laws
the next one is that we're almost
guaranteed to have property prices
increased
due to the very limited amount of land
that's still available for development
from finding the property to fixing it
up the fernwood group helped people with
every part of investing over the past
year home prices went up but las vegas
also saw rent go up something real
estate investors like to see
the attraction of the las vegas is the
combination
of cash flow and appreciation with a
small supply of homes on the market
investors have to act quickly
just like people looking for primary
homes you don't have three days to make
an offer
you have to do it in two days or you're
just not going to have a chance
fernwood and lee believe las vegas will
continue to be a popular place for
investors after the pandemic
as the population continues to grow in
fact
the property managers that we work with
we ask them
and they mentioned that they have more
out of
town tenants applying to
the vacant properties than local people
now back out here live in this home
they're doing work such as new paint and
some flooring and in the kitchen here
they're getting ready to
actually paint those cabinets now the
foreign word group works with 10 to 15
clients
at a time all of them are usually from
out of state the owner of this home
lived in hawaii reporting live in
henderson joe mullen 8 news now